achja arme ampel im multi krisenmodus
corona und wladimir putin auch der
könnte ja noch pandemisch werden im
sinne von globaler bedrohung sein
kleiner sidekick medwedew freut sich
diese woche schon öffentlich auf ein
zitat eurasien von lissabon bis
wladiwostok
da redet er wahrscheinlich nicht über
seinen nächsten interrail urlaub alle
die immer noch glauben man könnte mit
putin irgendwann zu einer art normalität
zurückkehren sollten seine drohungen
lieber mal ernst nähmen und das gilt
sogar für gesunkene drohung
[Applaus]
und tonen das baltikum gern auch das
saarland willkommen beim frühlingsfest
der völker rechtsverletzung wie gesagt
putin macht wirklich kein geheimnis aus
seinen ambitionen wir müssen nur zu
hören in russischen staatsmedien ist
inzwischen offen von der
entkriminalisierung der ukraine die rede
laut umfragen unterstützt zwar eine
deutliche mehrheit der russen diesen
kurs andererseits was sagen umfragen in
einer diktatur und noch gibt es zum
glück mutige reste von position sechs
polizisten führen einer frau empire
blumenstrauß wird gewertet als illegale
kundgebung
da dürften die russischen gefängnissen
am muttertag ja brechend voll werden
meine güte spätestens der horror von
butter also völlige von
systematischer terror gegen unschuldige
zivilisten verdeutlicht warum putin in
keinem fall gewinnen darf ja deswegen
muss man alles tun um der ukraine zu
helfen und wenn die ukraine nummer als
beispiel sagen deutschland wir bräuchten
dringend mal 100 marder panzer dann
antwortet man eben nicht sorry die
bochumer gerade für was anderes
vor allem wenn man sich vorher schon mit
helmen blamiert hat für was brauchen wir
dann bitte sonst unsere panzer gut die
bundeswehr erklärt das so ungefähr bei
der hälfte der marder sind wohl noch
sommerreifen drauf ist blöd denn hier
können wir auch nicht verleihen auf dem
christine lambrecht fahrstunden und ja
ein dutzend maler sind gerade in
brandenburg bekämpfen da den borkenkäfer
wieder andere werden in bayern als
kellner eingesetzt weil jetzt die
biergartensaison losgeht und
fachkräftemangel wissen sie ja und einem
marder haben wir beim ikea in köln
ossendorf gepackt und finden den leider
nicht wieder
peinlich vor allem von deutschland hat
putin in den letzten jahren gelernt dass
er am ende mit allen irgendwie
durchkommt und jetzt gehören wir zu den
letzten vier eu staaten die sich noch
gegen ein komplettes energie embargo
sperren tatsache ganz eindeutig sind wir
da der bremser
wegen uns konnte sich brüssel diese
woche nur zu einem boykott russischer
durch ring aus der wir im sommer sowieso
ausgestiegen werden wobei klar gehört
soweit natürlich hätte ein gas embargo
heftige folgen für unsere wirtschaft
ganze industriezweige müssten um ihre
existenz bangen mit allem was daran
hängt kann mir das mal jemand
anschaulich erklären und sich dabei
komplett in einer metapher für rennen
geht das die märkte sind ja dehnbar und
wenn die an einer einstelle so ein
bisschen wasserbett effekte haus dann
darauf und drückst du runter auf seiner
stelle geht's hoch und dann insgesamt
ist aber dass gleich viel wasser im
markt man irgendwann wenn die hand
wieder weggehen wickelt sich das schon
wieder zurecht so sich das vorstellt
dann schließt es eben aus dass die
matratze platzt oder dass das wasser
ausläuft
hwx metaphern fast schon rhetorisches
water betting tatsächlich können die im
moment nur noch zwischen unterschiedlich
hässlichen alternativen wählen ein gas
embargo würde deutschland wohl in eine
tiefe rezession stoßen regierung muss
schon auch nationale interessen
vertreten es ist ja so klar andererseits
was wären die kosten für freiheit und
sicherheit europas wenn putin auch nur
einen teilerfolg erzielt eins ist sicher
deutschland braucht ein völlig neues
geschäftsmodell jetzt wo die zeit der
blockbildung zurück ist china und
russland bilden eine autokraten allianz
gegen den west und das heißt übersetzt
wir müssen auch dringend was gegen
unsere abhängigkeit von exporten nach
china unternehmen alles auf einmal
entsprechend angespannt die stimmung
beim eu-china-gipfel letzten freitag eu
china gipfel und die begrüßung sagt
schon viel bloß kein lächeln kein zurück
winken die zeiten sind nicht danach
diesen blick können nur mutter von
sieben kindern den ich richtig geil
geübt haben ursula von der leyen heute
in kiew gut ab dafür und immerhin geht
deutschland jetzt ja man muss sagen
entscheidende schritte raus aus dem
russischen gas da sind plötzlich sachen
möglich die man bis neulich nicht für
möglich gehalten hätte wir schalten wir
live zu tina hausten nach niedersachsen
und sie hat gute nachrichten von der
windenergie front hallo liebe ja das
kann man wohl sagen deutschland hat seit
dieser woche viel mehr flächen für
windkraftanlagen
diese babys hier wissen nämlich weniger
abstand zum flug und wetter radar
anlagen halten und damit wird sofort ein
zusätzliches potenzial von 1 gigawatt
erschlossen das ist der stromverbrauch
von berlin sie haben ganz richtig gehört
sofort ein wort das im lexikon der
deutschen baugenehmigungen eigentlich
gar nicht vorgaben darf das ist ja toll
und sagen sie ihre mütze ist ach so ja
das ist die neue standard mütze für zdf
live schalten damit werden mein mikrofon
und die kamera betrieben vollkommen oder
nein flaute sekunde
umso lieber sorry für die kleine panne
wir laufen jetzt doch wieder auf
atomstrom und wie sie sehen bin ich
inzwischen kurz zu mir rüber gelaufen
denn genau hier am traumstrand von
brunsbüttel und an zwei weiteren
standorten werden jetzt schwimmende lng
gasplattformen gebaut dafür bindet man
ganz einfach alte tanker zusammen auf
den wird das flüssige zeugt dann wieder
in gasförmigen zustand versetzt und dann
via pipeline an land gepumpt und das
alles und jetzt kommt der absolute
hammer
noch in diesem jahr bedeutet alle
genehmigungen nach deutscher hoher
fernleitung verordnung müssen bis zum
winter vorliegen wenn sie das den
zuständigen beamten in der
bezirksregierung erzählen wissen sie was
der ihm sagt
der hauptroute wahnsinn was in
deutschland plötzlich alles geht und
auch die deutsche bahn wird ja
gelobt weil wir den transport der
ukrainischen flüchtlinge ich freue mich
das gar nichts zu sagen
exzellent managt die bahn
sehr geehrte fahrgäste das bordbistro
hat geöffnet die klimaanlage
funktioniert und alle anschlusszüge
werden planmäßig erreicht
aber ich bin es wunderbar ja ich ja auch
aber einiges davon hätten wir doch schon
vor jahren einschieben können wie das
mit der windkraft warum braucht es immer
erst eine mega krise wie sie hier mal
aus dem quark kommt riva jetzt freuen
sie sich doch mal alles ist neuerdings
möglich die ampel wird sogar dafür
sorgen dass auf autobahnen endlich
weniger lkw fahren mehr güter auf die
schiene kennen wir seit jahrzehnten
drüber jetzt soll was passieren wo dann
könnte man ja in dem spirit auch gleich
ein tempolimit durchdrücken
das geht doch technisch gar nicht hat
unser verkehrsminister gerade sehr
plausibel in einem interview erklärt
zitat so viele schilder haben wir gar
nicht auf lager und das ist keine
ausrede es scheitert wirklich an den
schildern dafür steht jetzt aber alle
paar kilometer so 1 hier gilt kein
tempolimit weil wir leider zu wenig
schilder haben
aber hätte man auf die schilder nicht
auch egal gen osten
[Musik]
tja energie embargo ja oder nein schon
jetzt wird allerdings vieles rasant
teurer kein wunder ein großer teil zum
beispiel der globalen weizenexporte
kommen aus russland und der ukraine
in deutschen supermärkten wird mehr
gehasst hat und brot ist plötzlich was
für feine leute
außerdem sind bestimmte produkte immer
öfter vergriffen und erstellen sich
völlig neue fragen sind mail und
sonnenblumenöl das neue klopapier nein
ich habe es ausprobiert und ganz ehrlich
da bleibe ich lieber beim 4 lagen mit
floralem dekor druck bei uns steigen die
preise aber in anderen teilen der welt
droht hunger als folge der ernteausfälle
in der ukraine und da muss die
weltgemeinschaft tatsächlich jetzt
handeln die eu-kommission zb schlägt vor
die vier prozent europäische ackerfläche
die wir eigentlich für den artenschutz
brachliegen lassen wollten doch wieder
intensiv zu bewirtschaften klingt
vernünftig
ministerpräsidenten sind dürfen wir
zulassen dass in der union vier
millionen hektar landwirtschaftlicher
fläche nicht genutzt werden das wäre
unvernünftig wäre sinnlos
wenn ich totaler irrsinn und wissen sie
was noch irrsinnig ist fast 60 prozent
unserer getreideernte wird zu tierfutter
nur 20% zu menschen futter und dann
nochmal 9 prozent für biosprit also auto
futter aber die eu kommission findet wie
4% brachflächen sind das problem 60
prozent des deutschen getreides landen
in futtertrögen und wie bei jeder guten
verschwörungstheorie stellt sich auch
hier die frage cui bono wer profitiert
genau dazu gibt es gerade eine ganz
spannende recherche
kühl
sie sehen harmlos aus aber haben es
faustdick hinter den flauschigen öhrchen
welche andere tierart kriegt ständig
fototermine mit prominenten politikern
kühe sind die wahren strippenzieher
sie sorgen dafür dass unsere äcker fast
nur ihr futter produzieren und sichern
sich damit die sogenannte
kindergrundsicherung der finanzminister
trug schon als nerviger teenager eine
krawatte das geheime erkennungszeichen
der kundin verschwörung und der
bundestag wird komplett ferngesteuert
von wiederkäuern am rednerpult who
marionetten wie alexander dobrindt sie
verbreiten seit jahren gefährliches
halbwissen das alles in einer neuen
recherche der polit magazin panorama und
monitor
das muss man sich ansehen die zahl der
green deal der eu von uche von der leyen
mit maximalem pathos als europas
mondlandungs moment vorgestellt wird
also man eben auf pause gestellt
wenn man als eu wirklich was gegen den
hunger machen will könnten wir zum
beispiel und jetzt nicht erschrecken
etwas weniger fleisch essen und stadt
tierfutter mehr brot für die welt
produzieren wir könnten auch endlich
anfangen weniger zu verschwenden 35
prozent aller lebensmittel jeden schritt
auf dem weg zum verbraucher verloren ja
das wären so ansätze statt einer
handvoll brachflächen wieder mit
pestiziden und dünger zu ballern denn
das artensterben macht ja keine pause
diese wunderschönen tiere sitzen bald
wahrscheinlich nur noch hier im
tagesthemen studio oh gott das wünscht
man es kaum mehr als ein viertel der
insektenarten in deutschland sind
aktuell in ihrem bestand gefährdet
insgesamt ist die zahl der insekten
schon um 70 bis 80 prozent
zurückgegangen trotzdem die rolle
rückwärts beim green deal das ist ein
ganz klarer erfolg der agrarlobby in
brüssel albrecht humboldt lobby ihr seit
jahren dort für die fleischindustrie
humboldt ist das nicht problematisch
rund 60 prozent der ackerfläche werden
nur für tierfutter also letztlich für
massentierhaltung gebraucht also erstens
schon das wort massentierhaltung ist
diskriminierend nur weil eine masse von
tieren hält ist er ja kein massen
tierhalter
und was spricht bitte gegen 60 40 ich
erkläre das immer gerne mit der burger
formel schauen sie mal ein guter bürger
hat 60 prozent fleisch und 40% veganen
quatsch drum herum also hier dings
schmeiße ich immer weg
im übrigen sind wir von der fleisch
lobby ja auch für artenschutz nur halt
nicht für jede art deswegen haben wir
jetzt eine eigene ngo gegründet wir
nennen uns ein herz für leckere tiere ja
wer möchte kann sich gerne für die
geringelte uferschnepfe einsetzen ich
kämpfe für den erhalt des spanferkel und
das extrem erfolgreich obwohl greenpeace
gerade wieder multiresistente keime im
abwasser von deutschen schlachthöfen
gefunden hat
wer krabbelt denn bitte bei anderen
leuten ins abwasserrohr und jammer dann
rum dass es da ungesund ist bisher kraft
unser erfolg in brüssel erklärt sich
ganz einfach da gibt es
25.000 lobbyisten und 1 2 artenschutz
heinis die ihn hier
wenn wir nicht sofort handeln werden
viele der eine million bedrohten arten
aussterben sowie der dole hier auf
meiner krawatte
allein in seinem bart leben mehr arten
als auf einem deutschen akw
entschuldigung wir können doch jetzt
nicht wirklich die ukraine vorschieben
um bei klima- und artenschutz gar nichts
mehr zu machen das verlangt ja auch
keiner aber vielleicht können die arten
zur abwechslung auch mal selber
mithelfen h ich rede mit der lieber
wiesenknopf ameisenbläuling
vielleicht einfach mal eine zeitlang
aufhören mit aussterben ist das zu viel
verlangt in diesen zeiten das gilt auch
für dich gemeinde mopsfledermaus dir
schulden wir gar nichts nachdem deine
kollegen und skoren eingebrockt haben
denkt da mal drüber nach umgekehrt wird
ein schuh draus mit unserer
massentierhaltung basteln wir doch
längst am nächsten virus
wissen sie was mich aufregt diese
unerträgliche arroganz die dabei ihnen
mit stinkt wir haben inflation verdammt
noch mal heißt wir müssen schnell
bezahlbares essen produzieren möglichst
viel auch produkte über die sie die nase
rümpfen ich sage es gibt ein grundrecht
auf
tankstellen frikadellen auch biete oho
doch und um ein zeichen zu setzen werden
wir beide jetzt gemeinsam diese aus
verschiedenen tieren zusammengeklebten
freezers verspeisen moment nicht
aufmachen nicht
[Musik]
gott was habe ich getan hat so gesagt so
europol
[Musik]
oh gott der dreh für die nk